il est bien
très droit très très carré à militaire
je suis Frédéric ternare je suis marié
deux enfants et je suis expatrié en
métropole depuis 24 ans et tu fais quoi
dans la vie et ben je suis pompier de
Paris
urgence config j'écoute
et c'est quoi c'est pour ça ma grande
bouillon
je connaissais très très peu mon île en
fait les sentiers je les avais pas
arpenter comme l'a fait mon pote là et
donc j'ai redécouvert en fait
véritablement mon livre le centre de mon
livre il y a il y a quoi il y a 6 ans en
fait notamment avec le Grand Raid une
des on va dire des fils de oui dans ces
années dans les années 86 nous la lance
nous pour faire un bac C et D
et dans ces années là dans la classe
n'avait plutôt des fils de on va dire
minimum de
l'instituteur etc
dans ces classes là elle avait déjà une
différence sociale et nous deux Frédéric
n'en retrouve nous au travers ça nous
j'ai quitté la réunion à l'âge de 21 ans
exactement voilà pour aller faire mon
service national c'était à l'époque des
choix purement personnels mais avec très
peu d'informations ce qui fait qu'on
partait un petit peu dans l'inconnu quoi
et puis on venait aussi d'un milieu très
très modeste ou on avait l'impression en
fait que les portes étaient relativement
fermées et on avait pris conscience
aussi que il fallait qu'on prenne notre
destin en main quoi
bon ben après l'entraînement bienvenue à
la case je me finais on est à chemin
Finette exactement c'est mon casse
bonjour
c'est ma maman
47 ans déjà
ma sœur Clarisse
mes deux filles mais elles sont grandes
maintenant la plus grande elle a 15 ans
et puis la deuxième elle a 10 ans et
puis elles arrivent bientôt là
on n'avait pas d'argent on a Périgueux
et se débrouiller comme un grand ah oui
oui il avait pas de sous quand il est
parti il peut pas rester sans rien faire
il faut qu'il est toujours quelque chose
à faire il va pas s'arrêter là aussitôt
qu'il a fini quelque chose il faut que
il y a des objectifs
c'est un c'est un cheminement très très
long
un parcours professionnel fête de
dur labeur de beaucoup de travail et en
même temps une très très bonne
récompense au final
on est au centre technique au centre
technique chargé
de toute problématique liées dans le
domaine des télécommunications
certainement système d'information c'est
pas censé être en vacances je suis censé
être en vacances mais mes chefs m'ont
dit ils ont installé à nouveau système à
la Réunion donc si tu peux je jeter un
petit coup d'œil tu y vas donc j'exécute
le but est de mutualiser les les
infrastructures de façon à ce que tous
les services de sécurité se retrouvent
sur le même réseau et puis se
communiquer plus facilement ce qui
n'existe pas aujourd'hui à métropole
puisqu'en fait pratiquement tout le
monde dans son petit réseau en fait je
suis dans un projet un projet en fait
préfecture de police dans lequel en fait
la les pompiers de Paris sont
parfaitement intégrées
c'est ce qu'on appelle une plateforme je
dirais d'appel d'urgence l'objectif
c'est de pouvoir faire travailler
ensemble la police et les pompiers
une douzaine de Réunionnais qui sont en
métropole et qui effectivement quand ils
viennent en vacances à la Réunion nous
rendre visite sans aucun problème et
beaucoup Perse facilement on a des
majors on a des on a des lieutenants on
a des militaires Durand enfin bref
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment un bon
vivier la brigade c'est un bon vivier de
Réunionnais et puis ça permet aussi
d'avoir pour nous des repères puisque
nous nous sommes sur notre île quelque
part et que beaucoup d'entre nous
n'avons pas quitté justement cette île
et donc là on a une vue extérieure qui
permet justement de nous apporter un
éclairage nouveau sur ce que nous sommes
en train de faire et peut-être aussi de
nous guider et de nous de nous donner
quelques conseils sur la route que nous
avons choisi pour dire est-ce qu'elle
est semée d'embûches ou pas et quels
sont les embûches auxquels nous devons
nous attendre dans l'avenir
un petit peu avec les avec les collègues
bonjour j'en connais pas mal quand même
la jeunesse que toutes les papiers que
si
comme que le Grand Raid comme
Frédéric l'exemple c'est on peut on peut
commencer à zéro et réussir quelque
chose réussir sa vie
où jeûne réunionnais aujourd'hui s'il
faut jamais abandonner toujours se
sentir utile même si on a l'impression
que on n'est pas plus mauvais ils ont
réussi maintenant je veux que le lien
tienne toujours beaucoup ça reste comme
ça entre frère et CE1 j'aimerais bien
quand je serai plus là qu'il reste comme
ça mais avec de la volonté du travail on
y arrive et c'est ça le plus important